pierre laurent le secrétaire national du
parti communiste français est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous à deux battants la dernière
ligne droite avant le premier tour des
élections législatives
suzette bloch de l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire vous interrogera dans
un instant justement sur vos espoirs
électoraux un groupe maintenu et
peut-être renforcer à l'assemblée
nationale c'est votre espoir et puis
peut-être alors entraîné par jean luc
mélenchon qui attirent toujours on le
voit les les lumières médiatiques
est ce que ça vous plaît tout à fait
vous nous direz tout à l'heure perrine
tarneaud de public sénat nous rejoindre
à tout à l'heure elle plongera avec vous
sur votre histoire familiale communiste
puisque chez les leurs on est on est
communistes de père en fils et fils à
prendre au pluriel c'est bien ça vous me
sentir et vous nous parlerait tout à
l'heure de voeux de votre frère ou
plutôt vous verrez c'est votre frère qui
parlera de vous je rappelle aux
téléspectateurs qu'ils peuvent
intervenir et poser leurs questions
durant cette émission grâce à
l'application tivi tchèque de notre
partenaire orange d'abord père laurent
quel est votre jugement tient sur la
photo officielle de françois hollande
qui est signée raymond depardon
écoutez je bougeais pas de jugement
particulier c'est pas un regard
esthétique alors oui mais il bosse
énormément on voit bien que chaque
président de la république ait said
imprimés enfin il photographe qu'il
choisit essayé d'imprimer une marque
différente pour essayer de marquer un
style mon après moi j'ai pas d'autre
commentaire
les sticks l'impôt non mais écoutez
franchement c'est pas depuis hier on
m'interroge là dessus comme ça sentait
un grand sujet très important pour
l'avenir pense pas que ça va ça va
provoquer un débat national
mais on a vite choisi un photos en
extérieur comme jacques chirac encore un
point commun oui mais justement c'est ça
que j'en de la spéculation qui
m'intéresse pas beaucoup parce que je
crois pas que chacun pense à ce genre de
chose enfin peut-être que si mais en
tout cas moi c'est pas comme ça le jour
il a l'air un peu guindée
sur la photo vous l'avez rencontré ce
mardi pendant presqu'une heure en tête à
tête
est-ce que qu'il est habité par la
fonction ou est ce qu'ils les gains des
dans l'exercice de la présidence de la
région et gardez pas du tout il était
très très amicale et très très
décontractée dans la rencontre
concentrez sur ce qui ce qu'il a à faire
et attentes lycée attentif à ce que
j'avais à lui dire parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de sujets de préoccupation on
était invité sur les grands sommets
internationaux moi j'ai beaucoup parlé
du prochain g20 de l'enjeu européen
qu'est ce que vous lui avez dit ça va
nous occuper toutes les missions mais
qu'est ce qu'il vous a dit lui il m'a
beaucoup écouté surtout il a confirmé
non il a confirmé que la situation
européenne était était préoccupante et
françaises et européennes mais elle sort
de la crise de la zone euro et la
situation européenne français sont très
liées justement est-ce qu'on va être
capable de desserrer la situation en
europe pour se donner des marges de
manoeuvre en france où est ce qu'on va
s'en donner en france pour desserrer la
situation en europe c'est la situation
était difficile tous les jours ou
presque maintenant le premier ministre
dit attendre le fameux audit de la cour
des comptes ce sera trois jours après le
second tour des législatives
1 et il nous a parlé de l'état des
finances publiques par exemple président
la république
non mais il n'a pas besoin on n'a pas
rentrer dans le détail de sa vie la page
web
on n'a pas besoin de franchement on
verra ce que donne l'audit mais on sait
que la situation n'est pas très bonne
mais voudra venir écouter on vient de
vivre moi ça m'étonne pas tellement on
vient de vivre cinq années où nicolas
sarkozy a fait croire peut-être qu'il
allait améliorer la situation en vérité
on sait qu'il a dégradé que la dette a
augmenté sous son quinquennat et que la
situation n'est pas bonne mais justement
c'est un bon exemple parce que je crois
que les politiques européennes menées en
france et ailleurs qui consiste à
imprimer des politiques d'austérité
loin de nous sortir des difficultés nous
irons fonce et c'est ce que j'ai discuté
avec le président de la république
vous écoutez moi je lui ai dit qu'il
fallait aller au bout de l'intention
gociations du tri mais attention pas
d'austérité et là il nous a dit bien sûr
il y aura pas de l'austérité vous l'a
dit non mais bien évidemment qui ne m'a
pas dit ça puisque vous savez quand ça
veut dire à d'austérité allait bien et
alors que le président de la république
est justement sur la position qui est
défendue par le gouvernement ce moment
qu'on va pouvoir concilier nos
engagements européens et les promesses
qu'il a faites dans sa campagne
personnellement je pense que c'est ce
n'est pas possible et que il va falloir
au contraire desserrer les politiques
d'austérité qui sont recommandées par
l'europe est à nouveau par les
recommandations barroso il ya quelques
jours pour pouvoir mener des politiques
de relance de l'activité et des
politiques sociales
c'est ce qui fait débat entre nous à
gauche qui a fait du mât dans toutes les
positions différentes
comme nous sommes sur deux positions
différentes sur cette question
évidemment avant et c'est pour s'arrêter
record elle veut de vous retrouver un
moment mais moi je crois que la vie va
obliger à écouter ce que nous disons
parce que par exemple j'ai reposé une
nouvelle fois au président de la
république la question du rôle de la
banque centrale européenne on ne peut
pas avoir une banque centrale européenne
nous sommes les seuls dans le monde à
faire ça qui finance les banques mais
qui ne financent pas les états à des
taux très bas
il m'a dit il m'a dit la question les
plus iconoclastes effectivement elle a
été une question tabou aujourd'hui cette
impression verte a comme quoi les quais
les idées que nous avons sont
progressent et il faudra bien aux tirs
comme si on veut réussir à lèvres
divergences avec le chef de l'état vous
parlez de la commission européenne un
petit peu de l'europe maintenant il ya
aussi peut-être des divergences de fond
sur les réformes structurelles que dans
la france a besoin et les deux les deux
sont liés effectivement fin président
des raisons sent que ça vient de
l'extérieur
non mais pour les mêmes raisons par
exemple nous avons un débat sur les
salaires oui je pense qu'il faut aller
rapidement vers une relance salariale
vers une politique d'augmentation
sensible des salaires la porte pour
l'instant c'est la douche froide pour
vous puisque effectivement le premier
nice dit que le coup de pouce un du smic
sera pas plus que 5% ou alors vous et
faites le calcul ça fait 46 centimes de
l'heure
vous demandez 2-0 après la douche froide
parce que c'est ce qu'avait annoncé le
président de la république il avait dit
il et qu'ils étaient 2 qu'il n'était pas
d'accord avec les propositions que nous
faisons c'est fait sans eux mais on en
est loin oui on en est loin mais c'est
un problème parce que si on mène pas une
politique qui d'un côté augmente
fortement les salaires et de l'autre
côté fait diminuer les charges
financières des entreprises parce qu'on
nous dit toujours oui mais augmenter les
salaires c'est pas possible
mais nous nos propositions elles sont
globales diminuer la pression financière
sur les entreprises les charges
financières que font peser les banques
et le coût du crédit et permettre de
relancer les laisse à leur élan mais
c'est parce que vous redoutez par
exemple le décret sur le retour partiel
à la retraite à 60 ans est ce que vous
avez peur là de ne pas être satisfaits
comme vous n'êtes pas sur le smic
écoutez sur cette question et vous savez
que nos propositions de retour à la
retraite à 60 ans ne sont plus globale
de la maison pour les travailleurs qui
ont commencé à travailler à 18 ans
puisque c'est cette nuit 19
il semble que les choses progressivement
par rapport à ce qu'on craignait au
début mais je suis prudent puisque tu
n'as pas que je les crée évidemment pas
pareil cas ça évolue plutôt positivement
puisque aurait la question par exemple
de comté ou non les congés maternité
enfin les annuités pour les femmes qui
ont des enfants ça avait l'air ne pas
être clair au début il semblerait que ça
aille dans le bon sens mais parce quand
ceux ci on va si on va vers
effectivement le fait de compter non pas
seulement les trimestres travaillés mais
ce qu'on appelle les trimestres validés
c'est à dire aussi les périodes de
chômage de maternité les périodes de
maladie
alors on va vers une situation qui nous
satisfait plutôt pour ces travailleurs
là mais je le répète comme vous le savez
nous avons des propositions plus en plus
simple 63 qu'il faudrait retourner par
exemple effectivement nous avons je vous
disais tout à l'heure juste avant de
venir ici j'étais dans une dent dans la
rue pour la campagne électorale avec
avec des candidats dans le 18e
arrondissement mon ami ian brossât
eh bien il ya une femme qui m'a dit
j'ai cinquante trois ans je cherche du
travail partout on me dit vous êtes trop
âgés donc il y à des milliers de gens
des centaines de milliers de gens qui
sont dans cette situation on leur refuse
d emploi parce qu'ils ont 53 54 55 ans
et dans le même temps on va demander aux
gens de travailler
enfin elle va leur accorder la retraite
uniquement à 62 ans c'est une aberration
du système actuel il vaudrait mieux
faire travailler les gens qui qui ont
entre 55 et 60 ans et permettre à tout
le monde de prendre un truc à villars
gisement du décret et andy favorable
nous dit on parce que la mesure il n'est
pas si coûteuse en tout cas moins
coûteuse que prévu mais est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas justement affecté cet
argent comment cet argent est bien pour
essayer de d'améliorer les comptes des
retraites qui prennent l'eau de toutes
parts par ailleurs comme quoi quand même
une rue barrée ces dames en 1 kw à 6 au
lieu de 2 d'avoir un débat parfois
dogmatique
on entrait dans le débat de chiffrage le
débat de propositions de financement
concrètement où on s'apercevrait que des
mesures qu'on prétend inaccessible le
son on fait tout à fait parce que
l'heure est toujours au tutoiement avec
françois hollande pour vous quand on se
croise comme ça oui mais évidemment dans
l'exercice des fonctions nous sommes
nous venons par exemple en tête à tête
quand vous parlez parfois on se
connaissait avant on s'était croisé donc
dans des responsabilités politiques et
précédemment moi quand j'étais
journaliste à l'humanité il m'est arrivé
de croiser et se découvre pas vous a dit
je te rappelle que la porte de
gouvernementaux ouverte enfin à toi et à
tes camarades communistes c'est moi qui
lui ai dit que sur cette question je
posais
une wii je posais une question c'était
nous nous allons au gouvernement si nos
propositions sont prises en compte
nous n'irons pas au gouvernement s'il
s'agit d'appliquer le programme de
françois hollande
nous avons appelé à voter françois
hollande pour battre nicolas sarkozy
mais nous ne partageons pas l'ensemble
de ces propositions nous en avons
d'autres qui vont plus loin
donc est ce que la majorité va prendre
en compte les propositions du front de
gauche à la réponse pour le moment il
n'y a pas de réponse favorable à cette
question et c'est pour ça que nous
continuons argumenté sur nos
propositions et a essayé de faire
évoluer cette situation nous s'il s'agit
de mener une politique
donc nous avons la conviction qu'elle
peut réussir nous sommes disponibles si
nous avons sentiment qu'elle va buter
sur des limites très vite
damien nous pousserons autrement qu en
allant dans le volet renouveau dans
l'instinct vous essayé de pousser en
ayant le maximum d'élus à l'assemblée un
rapport de mai on a déjà fait pas mal je
rappelle que s'il n'y avait pas eu les 4
millions voire a uni par le front de
gauche à l'élection présidentielle
françois hollande ne serait pas à
l'elysée non quand il faut prendre nos
responsabilités pour aller à la victoire
on sait le faire mais il faut enfin
tenir compte quand il faut en tenir
compte
et effectivement à l'assemblée nationale
avoir une majorité de gauche qui compte
de nombreux députés du front de gauche
ça nous paraît être une condition de la
réussite du changement et c'est à cela
qu'on travaille en ce moment on voit là
l'effet un rapport de force avec avec le
chef de l'état
oui enfin c'est que oui il ya des
rapports de force dans le pays fasse
contre la droite et il y en a à
l'intérieur de la gauche pour faire
progresser plutôt une idée qu'une autre
et vous avez aimé les derniers sondages
le parti socialiste n'aurait pas la
majorité à lui tout seul
à l'assemblée nationale il aurait une
majorité relative pas la majorité
absolue est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour vous mais ce qui ce qui
compte c'est d'avoir une bonne majorité
de gauche à l'assemblée nationale
avaient mais les mariés s'il a envie
d'avoir la majorité tout seul ça ne
semble pas être le cas il a besoin de
ses alliés les écologistes et le front
de gauche est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour être élu françois hollande
a bien eu besoin des voix du front
gauche donc en quoi ce serait un
problème qu'on soit obligé de tenir
compte de l'avis du front de gauche
demain à l'assemblée nationale pour
voter des lois
moi je trouve que ça serait plutôt une
bonne
justement c'est pas la même élection à
l'élection présidentielle il a dit je ne
négocie pas écoutez moi j'ai participé
puisque je suis sur le terrain tous les
jours y rejeté une réunion à
châtellerault à la fin de la réunion
publique que je tenais deux personnes
qui étaient là que je ne connaissais pas
sont venus me voir en disant nous sommes
des militants du des adhérents du parti
socialiste et nous sommes d'accord avec
une chose que vous avez dit c'est qu'il
faut que la majorité parlementaire soit
composé de toutes les familles de la
gauche et pas seulement du parti
socialiste et bien moi je crois que ce
serait une très bonne chose que quand on
prendra une décision de la majorité on
soit obligé d'entendre les suggestions
du front de gauche dont je voulais ça
serait chez le gouvernement à vous
entendre c'est ce que vous nous dites
alors on va voir comment ça se présente
pour vous les législatives justement car
le renvoi ça avec marie brémaud survivre
à la gauche du parti socialiste être une
force alternative pour durer le front de
gauche doit conserver un groupe
politique dans la future assemblée
nous avions déjà un groupe mais nous
voulons le renforcer un groupe ses 15
députés nous voulons aller bien au delà
des thèses députés parce que nous
voulons être présents sur tous les
dossiers
les questions financières les questions
sociales les questions culturelles celle
de l'école voulons vraiment pouvoir sur
tous les dossiers dans toutes les
commissions apporter des solutions
audacieuses afin de peser sur la
politique et gouvernementale il faut
remporter un maximum de circonscription
mais à quelques jours du premier tour le
doute s'installe
on peut pas savoir à l'avancé vous savez
très bien que compte tenu aujourd'hui du
paysage politique ne savons pas est ce
qu'il y aura des triangulaires est-ce
qu'il y en aura pas dans ce cas là
qu'est ce qui se passe
vous savez qu'il ya beaucoup d'inconnues
donc à aucun moment on peut faire de
prévisions c'est pas la météo c'est bien
encore moins précis que la météo la
science électorale bien moins précis
peut-être mais certains chiffres et
stimule abl le front de gauche a
actuellement 19 députés sortants il en
faut au minimum 15 pour constituer un
groupe
c'est le parti de jean luc mélenchon
peut espérer d'heureuses surprises à
calais dans le val de marne dans les
pyrénées-orientales
la situation s'avère plus délicate pour
d'autres candidats à paris en seine
saint denis ou encore dans les bouches
du rhône dans certaines circonscriptions
le front de gauche pg
avec d'un accord électoral avec le ps
est d'ailleurs rue de solférino où
gouvernement certains ténors socialistes
n'hésitent plus à exprimer clairement
qu'il se passerait bien de leurs alliés
écolos ou front de gauche à l'assemblée
il faut que l'on puisse se dire il y a
un président de la république qui peut
se reposer sur une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale majorité absolue
pour les socialistes au front de gauche
on espère bien conserver un groupe et
jean luc mélenchon candidat sur
médiatisé dans le pas-de-calais
penserait déjà à sa présidence voilà et
donc ses sept blocs peuvent alors on
nous a rejoint pour vous interroger à
son tour bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
non mais super lioran cette volonté
affichée du ps d'avoir la majorité
absolue c'est si vous êtes des
empêcheurs de tourner en rond mais pas
du tout je trouve même curieux que homo
mettre l'accent sur sur cette question
ce qui concer la majorité de gauche et
qu'elle soit composée des différentes
familles de la gauche ne paraître plutôt
une garantie c'est étonnant quand même
que quand il faut gagner l'élection
présidentielle
on compte sur les 4 millions voix du
front gauche quand il va falloir élire
une majorité de députés parce qu'aucun
député de gauche ne sera et de
socialisme sera élu avec les seules voix
qu'il aura eu au premier tour il sera
élu au deuxième tour avec des oies
socialiste des voix du front de gauche
et donc qu'à l'assemblée nationale cette
majorité tienne compte de toutes les
familles de la gauche moi je trouve que
c'est plutôt une garantie et ça
m'inquiète ça m'inquiète même qu'on
conçoit si obsédé à vouloir une majorité
absolue de socialisme hes calcia est-ce
que vous avez parlé avec monsieur ce
matin nancy a fait l'objet ce n'était
pas l'objet de deux larrons première
non mais quand je rencontre le président
de la république qui m'invite pour
parler des sommets internationaux du g20
de rio +20 du sommet européen
nous parlons des sommets européens des
sommets internationaux en question parce
que tout à l'heure pas seulement oui
mais on a évidemment brièvement évoqué
la situation mais par trop de détails de
la bataille législative un délit ce
matin le patron des sénateurs ps
françois rebsamen s'est quand même
l'article pays ou si vous êtes vous
inquiet les jeux je viens de je viens de
vous répondre je pense que sur le sur le
terrain moi je rencontre beaucoup
d'électeurs évidemment du front gauche
mais aussi les lecteurs de gauche plus
plus globalement électeurs socialistes
qui ne qui ne souhaite pas cette
situation qui pensent que la présence
d'un groupe front de gauche qu'ils
fassent partie de la majorité et qui
compte c'est qu'on doive écouter et
plutôt une garantie pour continuer à
avancer dans le bon sens par exemple si
on veut une vraie renégociation du
traité européen comme ça a pas l'air si
facile que ça quand même
pour le gouvernement français de
l'obtenir moi je dis que comptait un
groupe du front de gauche qui s'engagent
à ne pas ratifier un traité qui ne sera
pas changée et qui demandera la
consultation des français si ce traité
n'a pas été changée ce donné cette
garantie la cfu les plus utiles pour
tous ceux qui veulent le changement
justement un sondage ipsos logica vous
crédite ce matin de 21 23 sièges
vous pensez que c'est une fourchette
raisonnable nous espérer puce j'espère
plus j'espère plus vous savez a vu le
score que nous avons fait à l'élection
présidentielle et koro qu'on nous donne
pour le moment dans les élections
législatives
admettons mais on sera au dessus de 7
pour fin mai l'esprimo son mono 10% pour
voilà ça nous donnerait à la
proportionnelle plus de 50 députés à
l'assemblée nationale nous n'aurons pas
50 députés à cause du mode de scrutin
mais aujourd'hui nous en avons 19 il en
faut sensiblement plus dont 21 24 mois
j'ai un peu plus d'ambition ça on va
être en tête de la gauche dont plusieurs
dizaines de circonscriptions
donc on doit pouvoir aller au delà de ce
chiffre
écoutez je peux pas faire aussi parce
que sakho énorme et je vous dis on en a
19 il en faut sensiblement plus on en
mériterait 50 voilà si on nous en donne
si on nous en donne traitement ainsi les
électeurs ce qu'ils vont nous les donne
pas nous sommes en campagne si les
électeurs nous donne 30 députés ce
serait parfait vous en mérité mais ne
riez 50 alors le fonds n'a que nous
représentons dans la vie politique
aujourd'hui serait moins 50 des succès
c'est le mode de scrutin qui nous prive
de sept revers en national alors m il ne
mériterait une centaine selon patrick
albert et réalise un marocain qu'est ce
que vous en aurez un autre système
oui mais on peut pas faire un mode de
scrutin en fonction de tel ou tel parti
un mode de scrutin c'est l'égalité des
citoyens qui votent
s'il ya un problème avec le front
national et je pense qu'il y en a un
dans la république française est bien au
combat ses idées et le front gauche lui
va au combat contre les idées du front
national
donc c'est pas donc nous faisons notre
travail pour faire reculer les idées du
front national est par contre en matière
d'égalité de justice dans la
représentation nationale
effectivement le mode de scrutin actuel
risque de ne pas déboucher une
représentation juste circonscription il
pourrait y avoir une surprise communiste
il y en a il y en avait quitté dans le
pas-de-calais il y en a il y en a
plusieurs dans le nord il ya d une
circonscription ou deux qui peuvent être
gagnés dans l'aisne un communisme gagner
une circonscription j'ai été le jeu
l'autre jour dans le meurthe et moselle
dans le pays-haut en meurthe et moselle
dans la vallée de l'ong oui c'est tout à
fait possible dans l'isère dans les
bouches du rhône
non il y a dans la loire où j'ai été
aussi récemment du côté de firminy il y
a dans toute une série de
deux circonscriptions en france dans
l'eure où je vais demain soir il ya
écoutez je vais de circonscription
circonscription depuis le début de la
campagne puisque je ne suis pas moi-même
candidat je vais soutenir des candidats
et animer la campagne du front de gauche
il ya beaucoup de circonscriptions nous
sommes en position sont quelques un
candidat du parti de gauche n'étaient
déluge ce qui est possible et ce que
vous pensez pas que ce serait plutôt
gênant n'avoir que des députés
communistes pour la cohésion fallait
très gênant est injuste que le parti de
gauche n'ait aucun député et je ne le
souhaite pas et j'espère bien et que
jean luc mélenchon sera élu à hénin
beaumont et j'y crois très fortement
je pense que marc nollet ce qui est
député dans le nord devrait être élu et
qu'il le sera j'espère que nous
gagnerons le siège de joseph rossignol
dans le val de marne celui de françois
delapierre dans l'essonne c'est très
sain et sauf mais écoutez non ce sont
les sièges les sièges que je vous cite
sont des sièges sont des sièges
gagnables et je voulais line sommes
opposition conquête dont vos questions
l'échec de l'accord ps écologistes front
de gauche dans les circonscriptions le
front national c'est qui c'est la faute
à mêlant chant le fait qu'il soit
présenté à un moment sur les biens
socialise écouter d'abord comment est ce
qu'on peut reprocher au front gauche
d'avoir essayé de présenter un candidat
en position forte pour essayer de battre
marine le pen c'est un c'est quelque
chose que je ne comprends pas où nous
sommes mais écoutez il y a dans toutes
les circonscriptions france des
candidats du front gauche des candidats
socialistes nous nous avons mis dans
cette circonscription
un duo qui est un duo effectivement de
qualité jean luc mélenchon et mon
camarade hervé poly avec l'ambition de
conquérir le siège est d'empêcher marine
le pen d'accéder personne ne peut nous
reprocher d'aller à la bataille à cet
endroit là avec le maximum d'atouts et
bien pour le pour le pour le reste la
question vous posiez j'ai dit jusqu'à au
dernier moment à martine aubry et à
cécile duflot que j'étais d'accord pour
signer l'accord tel qu'il était bien
que je le trouve insuffisant et elles
ont refusé de le signer
c'est cela la réalité parce que je crois
qu'elle s'était au bout du compte il y
avait peut-être un peu trop l'obsession
d'avoir la majorité absolue sans manche
et je pense que c'est regrettable parce
que si nous déboucherons sur une telle
situation est bien là l'ensemble des
électeurs qui ont permis la victoire du
6 mai nos sirops ne s'y retrouverait pas
et ce sera un problème pas seulement
pour nous parce que nous serions
injustement frappés par cette situation
et ce serait un problème encore locaux
possibles avec des retraites dernière
minute
est-ce que vous pouvez le confirmer
écoutez pour le moment malheureusement
je ne crois pas qu'on sait enfin je n'ai
pas connaissance qu'on se dirige vers ça
mais ce serait nécessaire par exemple
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure j'y étais il
ya quelques jours dans la loire dans la
circonscription de firminy unieux ou et
candidat mot camarade christophe
faverjon eh bien nous sommes dans une
situation où la gauche est largement
majoritaire ou des mairies ont été
gagnées par la gauche par les
communistes aux dernières municipales un
canton a été gagné et bien à cause de la
division de la gauche actuelle du fait
que la corvair ps a imposé une candidate
écologiste parachuté dans cette
circonscription la gauche pourrait être
peut être éliminé du deuxième tour c'est
cette une situation invraisemblable je
pense qu'ils devraient on devrait
favoriser la candidature de christophe
faverjon qui permettrait à coup sûr de
gagner cette circonscription
donc je crois qu'effectivement c'est
regrettable qu'on n'ait pas signé cet
accord je les dis le jour mais les jeux
le contenu à le dire qu'elles n'ont vous
pourriez proposé où vous avez peut-être
déjà proposé à françois hollande pour
entrer par le gouvernement non nous ne
sommes pas à proposer des nous vous
savez que nous avons décidé au parti
communiste de prendre de décisions
définitives le 20 juin dans une
conférence nationale du parti communiste
après une consultation de tous nos
adhérents qui aura lieu le 18 et 19 et
la question essentielle que nous posons
est simple est-ce que la politique
gouvernementale prendra en compte les
propositions qui sont celles du front de
gauche
si on nous dit vous allez dans le
gouvernement mais c'est pour appliquer
le programme de françois hollande
rien d'autre ne pouvons pas aller dans
un gouvernement qui ne prend pas en
compte nos propositions
là par exemple sur les retraites vous
sembler un peu plus satisfait donc il ya
des avancées
donc elle ce qu'elle est la ligne la au
nom et sur les retraites nous parlions
de la mesure la seule mesure de retour à
la retraite à 60 ans qui a choisi
françois hollande dans le bon sens et on
se dit on lit cette proposition semble
au final après des hésitations quand
même pouvoir être peut-être bien
appliquée tant mieux on attend du mal à
comprendre comment sont qu'il faut aller
vers un retour à la retraite à 60 ans
pour l'ensemble des salariés ça ne
figure pas dans les engagements grand
soin lent nous pensons qu'il faut
renégocier vraiment le traité européen
moi je veux un engagement ferme que si
le pacte budgétaire sarkozy merkel n'est
pas remis en cause
il ne sera pas ratifiée par le parlement
pour le moment cet engagement je ne les
pages jeudi que sur les salaires nous ne
pouvons pas nous contenter d'une
augmentation du smic de 50 euros alors
qu'il y a des des milliers des millions
de travailleurs qui n'arrivent plus à
vivre
alors qu'il travaille pour l'instant sa
vignette de françois hollande 6 pour le
moment on continue de nous dire du côté
du parti socialiste ce sera le programme
de françois hollande et rien d'autre et
bien dans ces conditions on ne peut pas
prétendre former un gouvernement qui
rassemble l'ensemble des forces de la
gauche ça ne veut pas dire que nous
allons être dans une situation
d'opposition
puisqu'on nous dit si si la situation ne
bouge pas après les législatives
eh bien nous travaillerons dans la
majorité parlementaire à faire avancer
nos propositions et j'espère qu'elles
seront prises en compte et si nous avons
un groupe du front de gauche qui pèse
suffisamment et bien ce sera une bonne
chose parce que weezy par la majorité
parlementaire faire entrave est fermé
mais nous ne sommes pas dans une
stratégie l'échec
nous ne sommes pas dans une stratégie
d'opposition des produits n'en voulait
non nous voulons que la la le changement
réussissent c'est pour ça que nous avons
voulu la défaite de nicolas sarkozy et
que nous l'avons fait sans rien demander
en échange parce que nous sommes net sur
cette question nous voulons un
changement parce que nous côtoyons tous
les jours des gens qui souffrent et donc
nous voulons la réussite de cette
politique et le débat qui existe
nous à gauche c est ce qu on se donne
les moyens de la réussite ou pas nous
allons nous n'allons pas renoncer en la
consultation de faux militants le 19
juin 18 et 19 juin
et si les militants vous dise oui on
rentre dans le gouvernement sans
conditions qu'est ce que vous faites et
nous irons trou parce que nous sommes un
pays un parti démocratique
nous sommes aussi un pays démocratique
même si on vient dessous de souffrir
pendant cinq ans de ce point de vue mais
mais nous sommes un parti démocratique
donc il y à la décision des adhérents
est souveraine quand nous avons désigné
le candidat à l'élection présidentielle
nous avons procédé de cette manière
donc le si nous consultons les adhérents
c'est pour respecter leurs opinions ce
n'est pas pour faire le contraire de ce
qu'ils nous disent donc je crois que
nous tiendrons compte de la du vote
majoritaire des communistes lors de la
conférence nationale évidemment merci
suspecte d'avoir est avec tôt ce soit
encore je vous posais la question sur
les noms que vous auriez pu proposer
pour entrer au gouvernement parce qu'il
y en a un qui est cité s'est c'est celui
de nicole borvo qui aurait l avantage
pour vous c'est l'entrée au gouvernement
non de vous faire entrer au sénat
c'est parfaitement ridicule mais il ya
une chose mais ton mais je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que la décision chez
nous elle sera une décision collective
c'est pas une décision individuelle il
n'ya pas des individualités qui vont
aller comme ça au gouvernement c'est une
décision collective et je connais très
bien une colle borvo c'est ma camarade
mais aussi mon ami
donc il n'y a aucun doute là-dessus
entre nous soit y aura une décision
collective a commis soit il y en aura
pas à séparer dès lors à dire que c'est
elle entre au gouvernement vous vous
entrée au sénat
oui mais pour le voudrait plus 6 passes
ça se passera pas comme ça pour ce que
ce qui est de cette question il n'y a
aucun secret puisque nicole borvo l'a
déjà dit et moi aussi publiquement à un
moment où nicole
ne niera pas au bout son mandat nous
l'avons annoncé début mai je prendrait
sa place au sénat
donc c'est pas du tout quelque chose qui
est caché depuis les élections
sénatoriales pierre laurent sénateur
c'est aujourd'hui ou demain ou après
demain donc
alors je le disais tout à l'heure son
taux dans son tort ne vous en passez
sûreté je vous le disais tout à l'heure
issu d'une famille communiste vous avez
été nourris dès le biberon par
l'idéologie que vous portez aujourd'hui
tam tran huy à visiter votre album de
famille
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des parents
communistes tout le monde n'a pas eu
cette chance dans la famille laurent on
est communistes de père en fils de ses
années de jeunesse michel laurent le
frère de pierre laurent retient avant
tout un engagement dans la gaieté dans
la famille
la bataille politique a toujours été
joyeuse donc
donc on s'est toujours retrouver en
famille et on discutait 1re faisait le
monde en permanence alors un peu
utopique les laurent pas vraiment paul
laurent le père de pierre laurent a
gravi tous les échelons du parti
communiste jusqu'à devenir numéro deux
derrière georges marchais et députés
comme mon père a été élu député à
l'assemblée nationale bon bah on a
évidemment fêter ça ensemble avec les
communistes du 19e arrondissement de
paris
un souvenir effectivement très très
joyeux très très très amicale beaucoup
de gens qui l'entouraient pierre laurent
lui aussi a été numéro 2 derrière marie
george buffet avant de devenir
secrétaire nationale du parti communiste
et son engagement ne date pas d'hier
patrick le hyaric directeur de
l'humanité et compagnon de lutte se
souvient le lendemain des élections
législatives de 78 qui étaient très
mauvaises pour la gauche parce que
c'était une grosse déception il était
intervenu à cette réunion de notre
conseil national où il avait fait une
intervention très remarquée
et oui pierre laurent a su enthousiasmer
les foules pendant sa jeunesse militante
difficile à imaginer aujourd'hui dans
son parti où il paraît bien sage à côté
des tribuns comme jean luc mélenchon et
marie george buffet également un fort
caractère mais méfiez-vous de l'eau qui
dort
mais des faux calme
il reste un quart d'heure pour vous
énervez père le rang avec perrine
tarneaud bon je dois je suis quelqu'un
de calme mais ça veut pas dire qu'on
n'est pas déterminée qu'on sait pas où
on veut aller il n'y a pas besoin de ya
pas besoin de s'énerver et crier dans
tous les sens pour être extrêmement
déterminé vous n'avez pas contrainte
qu'on vous traite d'apparatchiks m'enfin
vous étiez quand même façonné pour être
première ce premier secrétaire non pas
du tout mais pas du tout parce que ça se
passe pas comme ça d'abord c'est
justement moi j'ai plutôt tendance à
penser l'inversé quand on a eu un père
dirigeant du parti communiste qui est
mon cas on n'aspire pas à le devenir en
tout cas nous dans la famille ça se
passerait comme ça
par contre s'ils n'ont pas du tout pas
du tout mais parce que moi j'ai été
convaincu par ce qu au début évidemment
c'est l'ambiance familiale mais ça
suffit pas parce que on vient on fait
pas tous la même chose que ses parents
aient mais il ya une hormis ans
militante et moi j'étais gpc ou même
aller ca / - vous savez il ya des ya des
gens dont il y en a qui vote communiste
il ya des gens qui ont été très engagé
très militants d'autres non et c'est
assez c'est une famille comme toutes les
familles tout le monde ne fait pas la
même chose ne vit pas de la même manière
ses idées ses engagements voilà tout ça
c'est laisser la vie normale et puis
c'est plutôt moi j'ai toujours été
effectivement un militant très engagé
j'ai été mais ça j'ai aimé mener ce
combat là mais j'avais absolument pas
besoin non plus d'avoir des
responsabilités nationales
il se trouve que en plus j'ai passé
l'essentiel de ma vie est toute ma vie
professionnelle comme journaliste comme
journaliste à l'humanité mais j'étais
pas du tout dans la direction du parti
communiste c'est les élections de 2007
qui ont été d'abord de le choc de 2002
puis celui de 2007 qui n'ont conduit
progressivement à me dire que j'avais
envie de m'engager aussi dont le
renouvellement du parti communiste et
dans son activité
et comme à ce moment là marie george
buffet a voulu justement promouvoir une
nouvelle génération on a été une équipe
à venir à la direction du parti
communiste grâce à marie george buffet
qui nous a fait confiance
et puis dans ce dans ce groupe ii
jeunes dirigeants et bien les autres
m'ont fait confiance pour devenir
secrétaire national et si je ne l'était
pas de vue j'aurais continué d'ailleurs
à le faire parce que pour moi c'est pas
une carrière c'est voilà c'est cdi des
engagements voilà pour votre engagement
dans le parti communiste pierre laurent
j'ai envie de vous poser une question
sur la cgt sur la succession difficile
de bernard thibault qui rate un peu sa
sortie est ce que vous êtes inquiet de
cette situation
moi j'espère écoutez je n'ai pas d'avis
à donner dans ce débat c'est vraiment un
débat qui regardent les n'est syndiqué
de la cgt et je suis trop soucieux de
l'indépendance de la cgt pour aider les
mets mais effectivement je souhaite et
je suis très attaché à ce syndicat dont
j'étais tout le temps membre
quand j'étais salarié donc j'espère
qu'une solution va être trouvée mais je
fais confiance aux militants de la cgt
ou et aux dirigeants et à bernard
thibault et je sais qu'ils vont trouver
une solution parce que les gens bien
tangent dans le pays qui sont attachés à
la cécité trouver une solution lartigau
et bien sûr vous savez il y a dans
toutes les organisations démocratiques
et dont les syndicats comme dans les
parties à des moments où des fois c'est
plus mouvementée que d'autres mais
j'espère que tout il va y avoir une
solution positive mais j'ai pas je vous
répète c'est pas moi de me mêler de
cette question et vous avez compris
pendant la campagne présidentielle que
bernard thibault préfère soutenir
ouvertement françois hollande plutôt que
votre candidat du front de gauche jean
luc mélenchon dont on aurait pu penser
qu'ils seraient plus proches mais
écoutez d'abord juste que j'ai entendu
pendant la campagne électorale c'est en
très net engagement effectivement de
bernard thibault dans la campagne pour
le changement
faut dire que nicolas sarkozy avait fait
des syndicats sa cible prioritaire il
n'est pas allé avec le dos de la
cuillère donc que les syndicats aient
envie et hué envie de s'en débarrasser
on peut le comprendre et ensuite dans la
campagne bernard thibault et la cgt
comme d'ailleurs tous les autres
syndicats nous avons rencontré toutes
les directions syndicales avec le front
de gauche
pas seulement la cgt mais la cfdt
françois chérèque
la fsu solidaires l'ensemble des organes
fo et la rencontre avec la cgt
au front de gauche c'était très très
bien passé nous avions énormément aux
convergences jean luc mélenchon en se
présentant face à marine le pen à hénin
bonbon est ce qui ne donne pas plus de
visibilité au front national
écoutez que cette question pour tout
vous dire commence à m'énerver et à
m'exaspérer un peu parce que oui ou non
elle n'est pas fondée
mais quand surgit le flocage des gens
qui pendant un an
parmi les commentateurs ont passé leur
temps à banaliser le front national à
nous expliquer comment tant que marine
le pen était là c'était plus comme avant
c'était plus le même front national et
c'est alors qu'en vérité c'est un très
grand danger pour la démocratie
et moi qui suis président du parti de la
gauche européenne quand je vois le
progrès des forces d'extrême droite en
europe y compris leur entrée dans
plusieurs gouvernements
je me dis qu'il y a des raisons de
s'inquiéter et qu'un parti comme le
nôtre qu'une force comme le front gauche
des signes de ne pas renoncer et d'aller
à la bataille
après les 18 ans sandra une nouvelle
vrai visage de marine le pen
non mais c'est pas grâce à jean luc
mélenchon nous n'avons pas attendu que
j'en ai fait mon choix il ya un moment
pour mener la campagne contre le front
national
pendant les législatives et
présidentielle parlant nous avons été en
pointe dans ce combat là et mon camarade
hervé poly qui est aujourd'hui le
suppléant de jean luc mélenchon dont les
médias ne parlent jamais et qui se
moquer royalement de ce que faisait
hervé poly dans cette circonscription
il ya un an il a décidé d'aller d'aller
être candidat contre marine le pen et il
a mené la bataille sur le terrain et
c'est lui qui a proposé que jean lui
viennent pour aider ce combat là donc
c'est pas un choix de circonstance c'est
un choix de faux nous allons continuer à
mener la bataille pour faire reculer les
idées du front anti hollande a raison de
ne pas recevoir marine le pen à l'elysée
elle se dit furieuse écoutez c'est le
choix du président de la république mais
moi j'ai toujours dit je la trouvais
rien dit j'ai toujours dis
qu'effectivement ce parti je n'ai jamais
accepté le discours de banalisation du
front national et c'est pas parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'électeurs qui votent pour
lui que ça fait de ce parti un parti qui
ne menace pas la démocratie
vous savez en grèce il ya un parti qui
s'appelle look doré qui est un parti
ouvertement néo nazis qui est rentrée au
parlement
ça ne fait pas un parti respectable à
mes yeux donc les idées du front
actional sont des idées dangereuses pour
la démocratie est une question qui vient
notre part notre partenaire orange
l'application tivi tchèque c'est une
question de caroline qui revient
justement sur cette bataille d'hénin
beaumont
le niveau de cette campagne cette
bataille de chiffonniers du teil à
laquelle on assiste est ce que ça
grandit la politique mais écoutez si
vous alliez sur le terrain vous verriez
que ce n'est pas une bataille de
chiffonniers il y à une bataille non il
y en a au nom il ya une bataille sans
raison que ça change et je suis désolé
il y as sur le terrain une bataille
militante qui comme je les dis est
engagée depuis plus d'un an par les
militants sur place qui est une bataille
d'idées qui est une bataille sérieuse et
qui justement ne se prête pas à ce jeu
là le ccl malheureusement on présente
cette bataille comme du spectacle mais
sur place et non sur place ce n'est pas
du spectacle
ce n'est pas du spectacle c'est une
bataille et puis si vous le trouvez ce
spectacle déplaisant et bien cesser de
braquer les projecteurs sur la
circonscription d d'un bon mot est allé
faire des reportages tous les jours sur
les circonscriptions où d'autres
candidats du front de gauche mènent
d'autres batailles c'est personne ne
demande ni jean-luc mélenchon ni moi
même que l'ensemble des médias soient en
permanence à hénin moment ce sont les
médias qui décide ça ce n'est pas le
ferons jamais totale à votre définition
du faux calme vous avez des tas
nécessaire de s'énerver pour affirmer
ses convictions et je me suis demandé si
c'était une leçon et jean luc mélenchon
non mais on n'a pas le même tempérament
ça vous a pas échappé
et tant mieux parce que dans une transe
une formation dans un ensemble de forces
comme le front de gauche
et bien c'est comme ailleurs il faut des
gens qu'on tel tempérament et des gens
qui ont péri quand on perd un ballon
qu'on n'est pas obligé on cherche pas à
être des clones et à se ressembler en
tout point on a chacun notre tempérament
je n'ai pas la même que lui mais vous ne
vous inquiétez pas ça m'empêche pas je
vais attaquer par des idées très claires
si justement marine le pen pour ses
engagements et son positionnement aimée
et jean luc mélenchon a à droit souvent
elles mêmes critiques il est renvoyé par
certains à l'ump notamment à son
extrémisme pour son discours haineux par
exemple mais franchement je le connais
maintenant très bien
c'est ce n'est pas du
tous quelqu'un qui porte la haine on lui
il est parfois emporté ça m'arrive de
lui faire cette remarque aussi il peut
être excessif est effectivement et il le
sait très bien
mais pour ce qui est des idées je crois
que nous avons intitulé notre programme
l'humain d'abord
nous portons des idées de fraternité et
je crois que notre manière d'être
nos pratiques politiques de la manière
dont la passion que nous avons mis à
créer le front gauche et à rassembler
des forces différentes montre que nous
sommes animés par des idéaux de
fraternité
parmi les questions qui nous arrive de
range vous n'échappez pas quand même à
cette comparaison avec jean luc
mélenchon allié amadou qui nous
demandent si c'est difficile d'exister
aux côtés de jean-luc mélenchon
mais vous savez je n'ai pas se gêner par
l'armée j'ai aucun problème avec cette
question je vois je vois bien que mais
vous savez l'image médiatique que nous
renvoyons les uns et les autres mais il
est pas forcément la réalité et je sais
bien même parfois on me le reproche mais
personnellement ce n'est pas la question
qui m'obsède le plus c est ce que je
fais prendre et c'est à la place
oui parce que des gens aimeraient qu'on
voit plus et c'est à moi je la question
qui me préoccupe c est ce qu à la place
qui est la mienne c'est à dire comme
secrétaire nationale du parti communiste
je fait progresser suffisamment d'idées
dans le pays et jette suffisamment mes
camarades a mené un combat que je crois
utile au peuple français
si je mène bien ce travail et je crois
que le bilan et la réussite du front
gauche depuis trois ans le score à la
présidentielle
est ce que nous allons faire aux
législatives me fait penser que pour le
moment je n'y arrive pas trop mal tant
mieux si je sers la cause commune j'ai
pas d'autres ambitions que celles là
bien laurent ce matin cécile duflot
s'est à nouveau prononcé pour une
dépénalisation du cannabis qui est la
position de son parti europe ecologie
les verts françois hollande avait dit
qu'il était contre pendant la campagne
est ce que c'est la première boulette de
la ministre duflot ça écoute et on verra
je ne sais pas comment le gouvernement
va gérer les différences d'expression
des demis les gouvernements pas toujours
eu la même attitude par rapport à ça
donc mais explique aussi ce qui compte
c'est le sait le débat de c'est le débat
de fond sur ça il
il ya un problème moi je crois que c'est
justement si je pense que c'est une
position trop simpliste je pense qu'on a
à la fois besoin du très déterminée
contre les trafics qui font beaucoup de
mal
d'une manière générale qui enrichissent
des gens de manière tout à fait injuste
et qu'on aurait besoin
en dehors de cette lutte contre les
trafics d'une vraie politique de santé
publique dont la répression à mes yeux
ne doit pas être l' axe majeur mais
plutôt une politique de prévention 29ème
édition du gouvernement voit la main a
pas de d'accord un à peu près mais je ne
cherche pas à thouars et hamdi s'est
investie en on est d'accord je cherche à
dire ce que je pense et ce que j'allais
finir des civils est-ce que vous auriez
préféré martine aubry à matignon pilote
jean marc ayrault
mais ce n'est pas une question personne
je connais l'un et l'autre politique
a priori on se dit est arrêté un joli en
temps je les entends tous les deux ils
men arena pas le répéter il n'arrête il
n'arrête pas de répéter l'un et l'autre
à coeur qu'ils font les mêmes choix et
qu'ils ont la même politique donc
et moi quand je rachète avec le parti
socialiste comment vivaient j'ai un
interlocuteur qui est le parti
socialiste et qui a une plainte qu'il a
déposée il a des débats internes mais
une fois qu'il a eus ces débats il a une
position et nous nous discutons avec le
parti socialiste
très bien merci père le rang d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir merci perrine bonsoir
à tous
est ce que c'est parce que vous n'avez
pas joué votre au solo peut-être
peut-être en tout cas j'ai depuis là-bas
ma prise de fonction il ya un an et demi
fait la démonstration tous les jours ma
volonté de jouer manière rassemblé
permet à koupala sur son plateau
donc vous dites linverse ont fait un mea
culpa vous détruit peut-être que j'ai
joué trop son ado je pardon j'avais
compris l' inverse alors pardon on a
assisté ces derniers mois une mode une
tendance une avalanche de mea culpa
lesquels sont devenus un ingrédient
majeur de la communication politique en
cette saison 2011 2012
alors pourquoi cette tendance à quoi
correspond elle est est ce vraiment
efficace de reconnaître ainsi
publiquement ses erreurs cette semaine
nous nous habillons en tout bien tout
honneur les politiques en pleine séance
d'autoflagellation déshabillons-les
présentée par hélène risser c'est
mercredi à 18h15 surtout lic sénat
d'une campagne à l'autre dans le gard où
marine le pen est arrivé en tête à
l'élection présidentielle rencontre avec
ses électeurs
à quelques jours du scrutin retour
ensuite avec michel crespy sociologue à
l'université de montpellier sur la
montée de l'extrême droite dans ce
département un phénomène bacinu on y
vient pour admirer ces vestiges gallo
romains ont profité de ces fériés animé
mais depuis quelques semaines le gars
est devenu l'unique département marine
le pen est arrivé en tête au premier
tour de la présidentielle
une demi surprise dans une région
l'extrême droite est implanté depuis 30
ans le gars territoire agricole où le
taux de chômage est supérieur de 3
points à la moyenne nationale direction
alès saint gilles vénérable où l'ump
tente de conserver ses sièges de députés
dans des circonscriptions où le front
national pourrait se maintenir au second
tour
c'est parti s'il est un département qui
incarne tous les espoirs du front
national c'est bien le gars
le gars qui a placé marine le pen en
pole position lors du premier tour de la
présidentielle en avril dernier 25
points 51 % des voix dans le département
devant d'une courte tête mais pas son
meilleur score en france
le gars vote à droite très à droite
depuis bien longtemps déjà en 2002 jean
marie le pen était arrivé premier
seulement cette fois ci plusieurs villes
du département ont dépassé la barre
symbolique des 30% des scores qui quoi
qu'on en dise inquiète les trois députés
de la majorité sortante en 2010 une
sixième circonscription a été créé par
le redécoupage électoral est ici le fn
espère entre un et trois députés
mais la candidature qui attire toutes
les attentions et celle de gilbert
collard un proche de marine le pen
favori des sondages il pourrait même
éviter une triangulaire en battant dès
le premier tour le candidat ump sortant
on est sur le premier tronçon de mon
premier mandat cette route il est la
connais par coeur un max roustan député
ump sortant est en campagne
déjà trois mandats au compteur ça fait
partie de la vie
saint geniès de malgoirès un village
sans histoire 50 viticulteurs réunis en
coopérative
huit cent mille litres de vin de pays
produit chaque année un fort
ressentiment entre l'europe et le front
national arrivé en pole position
ras le bol par le vol vote oral vol tout
simplement tout simplement écouté
entendu par personne parce que la gauche
et la droite au nom d'omar al ahmar ont
bon tout à fait plaisir on vote fn
max roustan encaisse les critiques
contre sa majorité sortante mais ne se
sentent pas concernés aujourd'hui la
réflexion qu'il faut voir c'est pas de
dire il faut pousser déjà que voter
front national
il faut essayer de comprendre pourquoi
ils envoient déflation pourquoi parce
qu'ils gagnent 1 que son fils trouve pas
de travail ou sa fille il voit arriver
des gens de partout
l'image quand la saint martin de voir
des toiles de tente avec les immigrés de
chou et lire que c'est quand même idiot
de faire réparer il vaudrait mieux
accueillir des gens leur fils un boulot
et un appartement plutôt que laisser à
la rue kent mais si vous dites ça peut
passer prendre raciste mais non je crois
que j'ai tout le front national au
second tour et n'y croit pas et compte
sur un scénario à la 2007 où l'extrême
droite s'étaient effondrés mais cette
fois le ressentiment chez des
agriculteurs pourrait perdurer et en
équipe on travaille on parle ici c'est
interdit de parler une enfant la
régulière belles jamais fait leur
professeur de français
direction saint gilles le sud du
département gérard bancilhon est à la
barre d'une exploitation familiale un
patriarche au grand coeur et bourreau de
travail lever 5 heures du matin pour
vendre ses roses ces fraises et abricots
mais fatigué de voir la délinquance
augmenté au mois certains jeunes
délinquants qui vole une voiture
une ou plusieurs de la même nuit s'amuse
toute la nuit à faire du gymkhana les
enseignes puisqu'elle donne on a fini ou
animer le feu où on le met dans le canal
dans le canal du baronnet le sommes par
pilote de trois la grande fierté de
gérard bancilhon ces cinq serres de
fraises qui pousse hors sol avec
arrosage piloté par ordinateur pour la
cueillette
ils embauchent des femmes en majorité
d'origine étrangère tamara wittes aïn
allah dit alors tamara étant d'origine
roumaine elle est assez gilles quand
même depuis une dizaine d'années nous en
avons eu une une seule autre qui est
française à française parce que eh ben
ils viennent pas chercher du travail et
ils viennent pas travailler les appels
il peut pas y viennent pas ils sont bien
la maison notamment mois des immigrés
qui travaillent qui ne font pas de
bêtises dans la nuit je ne vois pas
d'inconvénient chez nous on est là pour
travailler
voilà ce qu'il ne travaille pas ne
restent pas chez nous